[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
ز
في قبضتها عدا كيلومترين مربعين والخوف
يغلف موسكو في احتفالات يوم مصر
اننا بجد حزينون لهذا المال
البرهان يرفض تدويل ازمه السودان ويامل في
وصول مباحثات جدا لاتفاق يحقن دماء
السودانيين
[موسيقى]
لجنه بالكونجرس تتوعد بلنكن اما تقديم
وثائق الانسحاب من افغانستان او مواجهه
تهمه ازدراء المجلس
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
وسط حرب الرقائق الالكترونيه بكين تخترع
نموذجها الخاص في الدمج بين الرقائق للسد
الفجوه مع واشنط
[موسيقى]
ن
اهلا بكم عشيره الاحتفالات بيوم النصر في
روسيا سبق مؤسس مجموعه فاقنر العسكريه
الخاصه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في تقديم
الهديه للروس يفغيني اعلن تقدم مقاتله في
بلده باخموت العصيه مشيرا الى ان ما بقي
تحت سيطره اوكرانيا يقترب بالكاد من
كيلومترين ونصف مربع وقبل الساعات كان
بيوجين يقول انه في انتظار الذخيره لكنه
عاد ليؤكد انه استلمها
اعتبارا من اليوم تقدمت قواتنا لمسافه تصل
الى ثلاثه وخمسين الف متر اجمالا ترك
حوالي كيلو مترين وسبعه
تحت سيطره العدو ونحن نتقدم هذا وانحت
روسيا استعدادات الاحتفال بيوم النصر وسط
اجراءات امنيه مشدده وستقام الاحتفالات
بالانتصار على المانيا النازيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه في الميدان الاحمر في
موسكو والغت روسيا الاحتفالات في سته
اقاليم خوفا من هجمات اوكرانيه
هكذا يبدو مدخل الساحه الحمراء عشيه
احتفال روسيا بالنسخه الثامنه والسبعين
لعيد النصر في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
تشديد امني وتواجد لعشارات العناصر
والاليات في كل مكان داخل مركز العاصمه
صراع روسيا مع الغرب القى بظلاله على واقع
العاصمه موسكو ملف المسيرات الضاربه خاصه
تلك التي حلقت فوق مبنى الكرملين حول
المكان الى سكنتين وفرض واقعه من القلق
لدى القائمين والشارع الروسي
من يخاف من الذئب يجب الا يدخل الغابه ولا
مهرب من المصير فالابتعاد عن مثل هذه
الاماكن خوفا من المسيرات غير مجد فهناك
سيارات في الشوارع وسكوترات قد تودي بحياه
الانسان نستمتع بوقتنا من دون ذره خوف
اجراءات الاستعداد تستمر منذ ايام اغلاق
للشوارع المجاوره لمبنى لفتح المجال امام
الاليات المشاركه في العرض العسكري وضع
اعتده المواطن الروسي من قبل لكن ليس بهذه
الحده
لا توجد انظمه دفاع جوي تحمي بشكل كامل
القوات هنا في مهمه لحفظ الامن والوضع من
ايه اخطار
العاشره صباحا من التاسع من مايو هو موعد
الاحتفال بعيد النصر هذا المكان سيكون
حكرا على حاملي بطاقات الحضور هذه لكن مع
التدقيق والفحص الشديدين عبد الجواد
الروشت العربيه موسكو
في المقابل اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
عن احيائي ذكرى الاحتفال بيوم النصر في
التاسعه من مايو وفقا للتقليد السوفيتي
والروسي مشيرا الى انه سيقدم مشروع قانون
الى البرلمان للاحتفال مع العالم الحري
بهذه الذكرى في الثامن من مايو
ميدوس لنسمح بالاستيلاء على الانتصار
المشتركي لشعوب التحالف المناهض الهتلر
ولن نسمح باكاذيب كان النصر كان يمكن ان
يتم دون مشاركه اي دوله او شعب دمرنا الشر
معا مثل ما نواجه الان شرا مشابها
[موسيقى]
هذا لا يشكل سلخا بل هو القرار الصائب
والامر متروك للبرلمان وكذلك كان قد
تحدث الرئيس
سوف يعود البرلمان وهذه هي حقائق تاريخيه
يمكن
لالمانيا ان تنظر الى المساله من منظور
مختلف
لكن
يمكن ان لالمانيا ان تحتفي بعيد النصر
بصوره
متوازيه مع الغرب اليوم بالنسبه لهذا
الحدث فانه يشكر مفصلا تاريخيا في في
المواجهه التي دارت بين المانيا والاتحاد
السوفيتي ابان الحرب العالميه الثانيه لذا
لا ارى ثمه مبرر يدفعنا للاحتفال مع الروس
فيه في ذات اليوم وتذكروا
ان الثامن من ما هو اليوم الاساسي الذي
كانت قد احتفت به روسيا لكن جوهر الاحتفال
يجب ان يكون هو الاساس
وبصرف النظر عما يقوم به الغرب بنظرت من
اتخاذ نظرات لهذا الموقف لكن هذا ما حدث
روسيا هي التي بدات بهذه الحرب في اوروبا
هو لانه في روسيا
ينظرون الى استخدام القوه من خلال
التبرج والاستعراض بما يمتلي نكونه ما
يمتلكونه من قدرات لكن كل هذه التصريحات
وكل هذه الوقائع كانت ضربه من الجنون
لاننا سنتحدث عن سلاح روسيا قديما متجدد
قد يكون وسيله لروسيا في محاولتها صد
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بحسب تقرير
لصحيفه تيلغراف البريطانيه الحديث هنا عن
القنابل الانزلاقيه او المجنحه التي نراها
التي بامكانها ان تعطي روسيا افضليه نسبيه
في المعارك المقبله فكيف ربما هذه الميزه
لروسيا القنابل تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
نسبيا ما يبعدها عن خطر بعض الدفاعات
الجويه التي يتحكم فيها الرادار كما انها
تتمتع بقدره تدمير كبيره ايضا هذه القنابل
صغيره الحجم ارخص ايضا مقارنه بالصواريخ
الباليستيه انها قنابل موجهه وخفيفه الوزن
نسبيا وفي حدود الطن
كما ذكرنا السلاح ليس جديدا واعلن عن
الجيش الروسي عام
1994 القنابل الانزلاقيه الروسيه مشاهدينا
هي مصممه ايضا بشكل يمنحها امكانيه اختراق
الاهداف ذات التحصين والحمايه العاليه اما
ماذا هذه القناه في المتوسط فيصل الى 40
كيلومترا بعد اطلاقها عبر الطائرات
المقاتله وفق خبراء اوكرانيا بامكانها صدى
الهجمات باستخدام وحدات صواريخ سام او
منظومه باتيوت الا ان مواجهه صواريخ غاليه
الثمن صواريخ رخيصه ومعدله قد يكون جزءا
من الهدف الروسي لاستنفاذ الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وينضم الينا من جديد لنكمل هذا
الحديث من اكياف البرلمانيه الاوكراني
اوليكسي جونسارينكو اهلا بك من جديد يعني
بما يخص المخاوف من خطوه عسكريه عشيه
الاحتفال
يوم النصر هل لديكم مخاوف من ضربه عسكريه
روسيه خاصه اذا ما نظرنا الى اتساع
الضربات الجويه بالمسيرات والصواريخ التي
تتعرض لها العاصمه كياف وغيرها من المدن
الاوكرانيه بالاسبوع الاخير واليوم تحديدا
نعم انت محقه لقد استمرت روسيا بهذه
الضربات منذ اربعه عشر شهرا وقامت
باستهداف مدنا كثيره ومن المرجح انها سوف
تقوم بفعل الامر ذاتي في يوم الغد
ومنذ وفي العام الماضي ايضا في الثامن من
ما يقام باستهداف مدن كبيره روسيا يمكن ان
كما تعلمون تقوم بضرب المدن الاوكرانيه كل
يوم وتستهدف البنيه التحتيه وحياتي
الابرياء والمدنيين لذا يمكنهم فعل ذلك
يوم الغد هذا ليس بامر جديد بالنسبه لنا
التفاوض وليس النصر كما تطمح اوكرانيا
ولكن قائد فاجنر منذ قرابه الساعه اعلن عن
استلام الذخيره من الدفاع الروسيه وبدايه
قتال عنيف سيحصل بباخمت
اعتقد ان اوكرانيا مستعده تماما للعمليه
الهجوميه المضاده
وكانت
كما تحدث بعض الجنرات العسكريين قد رسمت
معالمها ولكنني لا اعلم متى سوف تكون ساعه
السفر لان هذا امر يبقى طي الكتمان لكن
ندرك ان ان عشرين في المئه من المناطق
الاوكرانيه ما تزال حتى الان بقبضه القوات
الروسيه ونسعى للسعادتها وسوف نفعل كل ما
بوسعنا لتحرير اراضينا وفي العام الماضي
كنا قد اظهرنا مدى قدرتنا ونجاحنا من خلال
شن هجمات مضاده كثيره وفي هذه المره سوف
تكون
العمليه المضاده الهجوميه ناجحه ايضا
فيما يخص روسيا تستمر في الدكه هذه
المدينه بهجمات متكرره
وباتت المدينه اثرا بعد عين في غالبيتها
وتذكروا انه كان يؤمه حوالي 70 الف نسمه
ونستولى استولى عليها الروس منذ يوليو
العام الماضي اي بمعنى مره عليهم سنه
كامله
للسيطره الكليه على مدينه صغيره وهذا يظهر
ضعفي القوات الروسيه في بلوغ اهدافها في
روسيا والعدوان الذي تشنه روسيا اليوم
واضح وسؤال هو هل بمقدورنا ان نقوم
بالدفاع عن كافه اراضين النعم سوف نفعل
ذلك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
رفع حلف الناتو من جاهزيتي وحداته الجويه
ردا على ما وصفه بسلوك الخطير الذي ينتهجه
الجيش الروسي بالقرب من حدود الحلفه واكد
مسؤول في الناتو ان مقاتل روسيا قامت
بمناوره خطيره كادت تتسبب بفقدان السيطره
لطائره البولنديه فوق البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي تلغي حفلا لها في
اسرائيل بسبب بنفسهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش
السوداني اقترب من انهاء وجود الدعم
السريع في الخرطومه وعبر البرهان في
تصريحات للاعلام المصريه عن شكره للسعوديه
على استضافتها للمفاوضات الهادفه لوقف
القتال كما اعرب عن خشيه القوات المسلحه
من انتقال الحرب الى ولايه السودان الاخرى
مشيرا الى استحاله الحديث عن اي موعد لوقف
اطلاق النار حاليا خاصه في ظل تمركز قوات
الدعم السريع في الاحياء السكنيه وشدد
البرهان على رفضه تدويل الازمه السودانيه
وافرض الاملاءات الخارجيه مؤكدا ان الحل
السلمي هو الطريق الامثل لحل الازمه
الحاليه
[موسيقى]
هذا والتقى السفير دفع الله الحاج مبعوثه
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه رئيس جنوب
السودان سالفاكير مايرديت في جوبا ظهر
اليوم حيث قدم رساله من البرهان الى
الرئيس كير تضمن التطورات الوضع في
السودان وشرحا مفصلا عن الجهود الدوليه
والاقليميه الراميه لوقف النار
لجنه من دعاه الحرب والحرب لا يقبلها اي
شخص نحن
نفضل
الحلول السلميه
ونفضل
وتهمنا سلامه وامن مواطنين لكن
الحكومه هي التي اجبرت على ذلك متى ما
وضعوا سلاح متى ما وضعوا سلاح سوف
يتم
العفو عنهم وادماجهم ولكن حتى الان هم
الذين يهاجمون ويحملون السلاح ضد القوات
المسلحه السوداني
من جانبه كشف وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
دينغدا وانا الرئيس سالفاكير طلق اتصالا
هاتفيا من المبعوث الخاص للامين العام
للامم المتحده في السودان يطالب فيه كير
دعوه الجنرلين لزياره جوبا لعقد لقاءات
مباشره
صباح اليوم اتصالا هاتفيا من المبعوث
الخاص للامين العام للامم المتحده في
السودان من بورتسودان تحدث فيه عن الاوضاع
في السودان وطلب من الرئيس كير بدعوه
القاده السودانيين الى جوبا حيث تحدث كير
عن صعوبه التنقل ولكنه رحب بالبرهان
وحميتي فيجوبا
بالتزامن التقى وزير الخارجيه المصريه
سامح شكري في العاصمه تشاديه الرئيس محمد
ادريس ديبي في مستهل زيارته لتشاد وجنوب
السودان وقال شكري ان هناك رؤيا مشتركه
بين مصر وتشاد وجنوب السودان فيما يتعلق
باهميه وقف الاقتتال بالسودان والعوده
للحوار السياسي كما اكد ان مصر ترغب في
تكثيف التشاور من اجل مصلحه السودان وضمان
عدم تاثوري الدول الجوار جراء الصراع
وبحث وزير الخارجي السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان تطورات الاوضاع في السودان مع مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
حسب وكاله الانباء السعوديه ناقش الاتصال
مستجدات المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه التي
تهدف لتهيئه الارضيه اللازمه للحوار
رحب رئيس حزب المؤتمر السوداني عمر دقير
بالتزامن وزير الخارجي السعودي بالوقوف
الى جانب السودان حتى الوصول الى بر
الامانه واضافت جير ان فرص نجاح المبادره
التي تقودها الرياض بمعيه واشنطن عاليه
وهو ما سيسمح بتخفيف حده الكارثه
الانسانيه وتهيئه الارض لوقف دائم للنار
وحذر من اطاله امد الحرب مما يتيح الفرصه
لاصحاب الاجندات الخارجيه بجر البلاد نحو
الفوضى الشامله وبخصوص مفاوضات جدا جددت
جير امله في ان يقدر المتفاوضون معاناه
الشعب للتوافق على الترتيبات تعالج
الكارثه الانسانيه
وللاطلاع على تطورات الاوضاع على الارض
ينضم الينا من الخرطومه الصحفيه عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك السيد عمار يعني فعليا اخر
التحديثات المتوفره حول تطورات الاوضاع
تحديدا بالعاصمه
الاشتباكات وايضا يعني تمركز تحديدا قوات
الدعم السريع يعني تقول بانها تسيطر على
مراكز مهمه بالعاصمه ما صحه هذه الاقوال
اهلا بك راويه واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم اخر التحديثات وفي هذه اللحظات ربما
انخفض صوت البنادق والمدفعيه الثقيله التي
كانت قبل الساعه من الان نشهد هدوءا نسبيا
لكنه حذر باعتبار ان الحركه في هذا
التوقيت تبدو صعبه
باعتبار ايضا كذلك بان الكهرباء تنقطع من
عدد من الاحياء وتعود لعدد من الاحياء
وايضا تكثر في هذه اللحظات عدد كبير جدا
من عمليات السرقه لكثير من اللصوص الذين
ربما يكونوا مسلحين باسلحه بيضاء او غيرها
في هذه اللحظات الوضع الميداني بحسب
المعلومات الوارده بانهم يشير للاستقرار
التام والهدوء في عدد كبير من احياء
العاصمه الخرطوم وحتى المناطق التي دارت
فيها اشتباكات قبل ساعه ونصف بحسب ايضا
سؤالك الراويه فيما يخص المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها قوه الدعم السريع هو تصريحهم
بانهم يسيطرون على اكثر في المئه من
العاصمه الخرطوم نعم الدعم السريع بحسب
بيانات كثيره وحتى بحسب بيانات الجيش التي
تحدثت على انه يضع يده على عدد كبير من
المقر الاستراتيجيه في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وينتشر في جزء كبير من مدينه بحري
وايضا كذلك من منطقه شرق النيل واما مدينه
ام درمان فيتواجد الدعم السريع في ام
درمان القديمه في محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون
وعدد من الاحياء والشوارع والاذيقه
القريبه من محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون الجيش
تحدث في كثير من البيانات بان الدعم
السريع عاث فسادا في تلك المناطق وربما
تضررت كثير جدا من المناطق خاصه كان
الحديث عن معهد او مقر الفحص القومي
المعروف استاكوا هذا المكان لما يحويه من
فحوصات وعينات لعدد كبير جدا من الفيروسات
كامراض الشلل وعدد من الاصابات والامراض
الاخرى ايضا تحدث الجيش من خلال اشارات
كثيره جدا
ان الدعم السريع ما زال يتواجد ويتحصن
بالقصر الجمهوري هو ايضا مطار الخرطوم
ومناطق من القياده العامه ولكن ايضا
بيانات اخرى من الدعم السريع تبث بين فتره
واخرى وتثبت من خلالها انها تنتشر وتسيطر
على عدد من المناطق شكرا جزيلا لك عمار
ابو شيبه الصحفي حدثنا من الخ
ومع استمرار الحرب في السودان فرع
الكثيرون من العاصمه الخرطوم في رحله
مكلفه وشاقه على الطريق الى الحدود مع مصر
في
الخروج من العاصمه السودانيه بين نيران
القصف والرصاص ليس كل الخطر وتخطي
المواجهات لا يعني انتهاء رحله النزوح
فويلات النزوح متعدده كما قال بعض الناجين
من الاقتتال وانا غير كده انا باخد
انسولين يعني ثلاثه يوم انا ما اخذتهم
انا خليت هناك اموالي وحالتي كلها في
الخرطوم وشغليه الخرطوم فجيت مع الضربه
اول ما حصل اشتباك شديد انا خليت كل حاجه
يعني اجيت ما امتلك اي حاجه هنا
مساجد ومدارس حلفا وحتى شوارعها باتت ماوى
للسودانيين الذين خرجوا تاركين خلفهم
ممتلكاتهم اخترنا المسجد عشان هو حته يعني
واضحه وقريبه من الخدمات يعني متوفر اي
حاجه قريبه منها قاعدين في الحين بس
[موسيقى]
بلد الناس لكن عشان السودان اتخربش كذا
ماشيه
منطقه وادي حلفله التي تبعد 25 كيلو مترا
جنوبي الحدود المصريه اصبحت مزدحمه
بالنازحين علما ان الخارجيه المصريه اكدت
ارسال تعزيزات لتسريعها فيما لا يزال نحو
سته الاف جواز سفر بانتظار تاشيرات الدخول
وجيت مع ابني
ابني بيستحق تاشيره
فراحوا قدم
للتاشيره ولغايه اليوم احنا ما لاقيين
يعني اجابه اهلي وادي حلفا يقدمون مساعدات
ولو بابسط الطرق لضيوفهم من الخرطوم والله
احنا ما اخترناش المدرسه هم في مبادره كان
من اهل المنطقه هنا
ودخلونا المدرسه ودون المراتب والملايات
ويجيبوا لنا مرات شاي ولبن ومرات عيش قبل
شوي نجيب
ورغم الامهم فالابتسامه لا تفارق وجوه
بعضهم املا في غدا قد يعودون فيه لمنازلهم
وللحياه الامنه مين مهندس العربيه
[موسيقى]
علينا وزير العدل التركي عن اعتقال 13
شخصا بتهمه اثاره اعمال العنف في تجمع
للمعارضه التركيه اثناء كلمه لاكرم امام
اوغلو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول الذي كان يتحدث
بالنيابه عن كمال كليتش جار اوغلو مرشح
المعارضه للرئاسه
[موسيقى]
كنا نتحدث الى مواطني ارد روم كما نفعل في
كل مكان ثم نرى الحجاره تمطر علينا في كل
مكان وهناك صور بلا منازع ان الشرطه لم
تحرك ساكنا كانت هذه اوامر تلقوها وكانت
هذه اوامر لا يمكن ان يكون اي شيء اخر
كانت هناك اوامر بعدم التدخل وهناك خراطيم
مياه لكن الحجاره كانت تلقى على رؤوس
الناس كان علينا الصعود فوق الحافله وكنا
نرجم بالحجاره ويمكنك ان ترى حجم الحجاره
من الصور اوقفت حديثي بعد خمس دقائق من
ذلك الحدث لان الحجاره التي تم رميها كانت
تتطاير فوق رؤوسنا
وتضرب الناس في الراس والعينين اصيب عشره
الى 15 شخصا امام عين مباشره
استخدمت المعارضه اللاجئين السوريين كورقه
ضغط ضد الحكومه خلال العقد الماضي ويعتبر
العلمانيون الاتراك في مقدمه الداعين
لترحيل السوريين حيث
ركزت المعارضه خطابها بالكامل على طرد
السوريين واعادتهم خلال سنتين الى بلادهم
بينما تعهد اردوغان قبل عده اشهر باعاده
السوريين الى مناطق امنه ستقيمها بلاده
قرب الحدود
عند تصوير اي تقرير عن اللاجئين السوريين
في اسطنبول يكون حي الفاتح وجهتنا
الرئيسيه لماذا هذا الحي على وجه التحديد
لان عشرات بل مئات المحال والمطاعم
والشركات السوريه اختار اصحابها الانطلاق
من هذا الحي التاريخي الذي يعتبر الاكثر
استقطابا للاجئين
اذا القسم الاكبر من النشاط التجاري
والاقتصادي للاجئين السوريين يتركز في حي
الفاتح وهذا يعني بالضروره عماله سوريه
كبيره تعمل هنا كعماد الذي يعمل في احد
محل الحلويات وعماد كغيره من اللاجئين
يخشى نتائج الانتخابات القادمه يعني هو
بس الفكره انه ما نجح الرئيس اردوغان يعني
في
تخوفها لبعدين وين راح نروح بس ان شاء
الله ما بصير غير خير استخدمت المعارضه
اللاجئين السوريين كورقه ضد الحكومه خلال
العقد الماضي من خلال تحميلهم مسؤوليه
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه السيئه الانتقادات
تجاه اللاجئين تصاعدت بشكل كبير خلال
العامين الماضيين وقاد هذه الحمله على وجه
التحديد السياسي المتطرف المعادي للاجئين
اوميت اوز
السوريون سنعيدهم الى بلدهم والاشياء
الاخرى لا تهمك انت لست مواطنا تركيا
سنعيدك الى بلدك
مرشح المعارضه للرئاسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو
تعهد مرارا باعاده اللاجئين اذا وصل
للرئاسه التخوفات موجوده السبب التخوفات
حقيقه صادره من وين صادرا من استخدام
الاحزاب في تركيا لهذه الورقه من اجل
الانتخابات دائما التوجه لورقه اللاجئين
واستخدامها بطرق واساليب تعتبر لانك سوري
مستفزه وتعتبر مخيفه نوعا ما لماذا نحن
الحلقه الاضعف في النهايه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان تعهد كذلك باعاده اللاجئين الى
مناطق امنه شمالي سوريا مراقبون ارجاع
موقف اردوغان لتنامي حاله شعبيه تريد حل
مشكله اللاجئين واع ادتهم وبالتالي اراد
الرئيس سحب هذه الورقه من معارضه
وفق القانون الرئيسي هو من يقرر استقبال
موجات كبيره من مواطن دوله اخرى يتعرضون
للاضطهاد وفي ذات الوقت بقرار اداري من
الرئيس يمكن ان تتم اعادتهم لكن بشرط ضمان
شروط الحياه الانسانيه لهم في بلادهم
بالمحصله وكما في كل انتخابات تشهدها
البلاد حاله الخوف والقلق لدى اللاجئين
تبلغ اعلى مستوياتها قبل الانتخابات بايام
فحملات الوعيد والتهديد الصادره من
المنابر السياسيه تفوق بكثير بعض
التطمينات التي تاتي على خجل من هنا وهناك
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
الانتخابات التركيه هذا العام تاتي بعد
زلزال مدمر شهدته البلاد ما يعيد الى
الذاكره زلزال عام 1999 الذي تابعه
انتخابات اطاحت بحزب الشعب الجمهوري لصالح
العداله والتنميه فهل سيقلب الزلزال
الجديد الحكمه مره اخرى في تركيا في ظل
الاوضاع الصعبه التي يعاني منها الاتراك
تقرير يلقي الضوء
عام
1999 من القرن الماضي ضرب زلزال مدمر
تركيا اثاره الكارثيه غيرت وجه الحكم
اطاحت بحزب الشعب الجمهوري لصالح حزب
العداله والتنميه اليوم وبعدما يزيد عن 20
عاما تركيا في مواجهه اثار زلزال مدمرا
وانتخابات فهل سيقلب الزلزال الجديد الحكم
مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
باستمرار حزب العداله والتنميه في الفوز
انه قدم للناخبين مزايا ماديه معينه بصرف
النظر عن قاعده الناخبين القويه وهذه هي
المره الاولى التي يبدو ان هذا الامر لن
يعمل بسبب الاقتصاد بسبب التضخم الكبير
وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
الامر يضر بشده بجيوب الناس واعتقد ان هذا
هو السبب في ان هذه الانتخابات لا تبدو
مضمونه الفوز بالنسبه لاردوغان
في السوق فاكهه طازجه وخضار لكن شرائها
صعب الاحوال المعيشيه صعبه الليره التركيه
منهاره والتضخم كبير في الشوارع صور
لاردوغان واخرى لكم
كل يحاول استثمار الكارثه بين وعود
بالبناء والانقاذ واتهامات بالمسؤوليه
والتقصير
حمل ترشح
كفهي الذي يرغب بحكم مغاير لما عايشه منذ
20 عاما
وعوامل ترشح كفه اردوغان استقطاب
ايديولوجي محافظ يميل لكفه العداله
والتنميه لكن لا شيء يغير وجه الحكم في
بلد ما اكثر من زلزال
[موسيقى]
حدد رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس
النواب الامريكيه مايكل مقبول هدد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
باتهامه بازدراء الكونغرس اذا فشلت وزاره
الخارجيه في تقديم الوثائق المطلوبه بشان
الانسحاب من افغانستان
الغى اتبعثت الاتحاد الاوروبي في اسرائيل
حفل استقبال دبلوماسي بمناسبه يوم اوروبا
بسبب المشاركه المزمعه لوزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بن خفيره اوضحت ان
البعثه اتخذت هذا القرار لانها لا تريد
توفير منبر لشخص تتعارض ارائه مع القيم
الاوروبيه
الحياه بالنسبه لكثير من السودانيين في ظل
الحرب عادت لعقود مضت وربما اكثر تابعونا
مع بعض
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد طلبه وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه للولايات المتحده باحترام سياده
بيكين وامنها والعوده الى العقلانيه لضمان
تحقيق النجاح المتبادل في تنميه افضل
للبلدين
يجب ان لا تتحدث الولايات المتحده عن
قنوات الاتصال والحوار من ناحيه بينما
تقوم بقمع الصين من ناحيه اخرى على
الولايات المتحده احترام الصين وعدم تجاوز
الخطوط الحمر عليها التوقف عن الاضرار
بسياده الصين وامنها ومصالحها التنمويه
وعلى وجه الخصوص التعامل بشكل صحيح مع
قضيه تايوان
جانب مما تدعو اليه بكين يتعلق بالعقبات
الامريكيه على الرقائق واشباه الموصلات
لكن هذه العقوبات دفعت الشركات الصينيه
لتطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي بطريقتها فكما
يقال ربما داره في التقرير خاص
فيه ان الشركات الصينيه تدرس تقنيات تسمح
لها بتحقيق اداء ذكاء اصطناعي متطور
باشباه موصلات اقل قوه بحسب التقرير من
بين الشركات التي تعمل على هذا النسق
هواوي وعلي بابا والتي تحاول استخراج
فائده اكبر من رقائق الكمبيوتر الحاليه
ومع احتدام السباق لصنع نماذج شبيهه
استبعدت الصين من الحصول على رقائق من اي
مئه وهي
انفيديا هي الاكثر شهره في تطوير الذكاء
الاصطناعي والجيل التالي هو اتش 100 الذي
تم اصداره في مارس الماضي لذلك تعمل
العديد من الشركات الصينيه على الجمع بين
ثلاث او اربع شرائح اقل تقدما لمحاكاه
اداء اقوى معالجات
انفيديا في ابريل كشفت تنسنت عن مجموعه من
الشرائح المتصله لتدريب نموذج ذكاء
اصطناعي على نطاق واسع اما شركه هواوي فقد
تمكنت من تطوير نموذج اولي للذكاء
الاصطناعي باسم بانجو سيجما
بان وصل بانجو وصل الى داء متطور في بعض
مهام اللغه الصينيه بما في ذلك فهم
القراءه والتحديات النحويه وغيرها دون
الاستعانه برقائق ان فيديو وينضم الينا من
عمان رائد سمور الخبير في امن المعلومات
للتحدث عن هذا الموضوع اهلا بك سيد رائد
يعني ما الذي نعرفه عن تفاصيل الخطه
البديله
للصين باطار طبعا حرب الرقائق الالكترونيه
التي
نشهدها بالاشهر الاخيره
مساء الخير بالبدايه حقيقه يعني الصراع
الصيني الامريكي بموضوع مساله تحديدا
الرقائق او اشباه الموصلات
يعني موضوع
متقدم جدا في هذه المعركه
الاقتصاديه السياسيه العسكريه لانه
الرقائق تدخل في معظم الصناعات الخاصه
بالتصنيع العسكري وتدخل ايضا في موضوع
الذكاء الاصطناعي وتتداخل ايضا في موضوع
المعالجات الكبرى التي تعالج المعلومات
بشكل كبير جدا الان الان اعتقد انه موضوع
العقوبات الامريكيه على على الصين
وعدم تزويد الصين بمعالجات خاصه او بمثل
هذه
الرقائق الخاصه للذكاء الاصطناعي سوف يدفع
الصين الى الامام باتجاه خطوات البحث عن
بدائل مثل هذه التقنيات
بالتالي هناك مصانع جديده تنشا لتصنيع هذه
الرقائق لكن الحقيقه هي تحتاج الى فتره
زمنيه طويله حتى تصل الى سن الرشد في
عمليه التصنيع يعني لابد وان تصل تدخل في
مراحل معينه حتى تصل الى مرحله الاستقرار
في عمليه الانتاج والمنافسه الان المنافسه
عالميا وصلت الى اثنين نانو متر وبالتالي
يعني هذه المساله تحتاج الى بحث علمي طويل
وتحتاج الى مجهود كبير جدا حتى يصلوا الى
منافسه بمثل هذه المساله تكلفه نعم
التكلفه التكلفه عاليه جدا التكلفه عاليه
جدا
وليش الصراع العنقائم على تايوان الصراع
قائم على تايوان لانه هي فيها مصانع قائمه
الان وتنتج اجود انواع المعالجات بالتالي
اولا المصنع الواحد يفوق كلفته اكثر من 20
يحتاج الى فتره زمنيه فترات زمنيه طويله
حتى يصل الى مرحله الاستقرار في عمليه
الانتاج ونعتقد في شركه في تايوان اللي هي
تي اس ام سي الان بدات ببناء مصنع في
المانيا وهذا يمكن لتدارك المخاطر المخاطر
الحرب التي من الممكن ان تندلع ما بين
الصين وما بين تايوان او ما بين الولايات
المتحده والصين الكل فعاليه جدا نعم وليست
سهله وتحتاج الى فترات زمنيه طويله ونحن
في هذا السباق يعني اللي بده يتاخر فيه
فترات زمنيه هو خاسر حقيقه فبالتالي هم
يحاولوا ان يستعيضوا بعمليات التعويض هذه
من خلال دمج اكثر من
جين من الرقائق
للوصول الى اداء انفينيا هل يمكن الوصول
الى نوعيه هذا هذه الشرائح نوعيه ادائها
انا اعتقد ان الصين قادره على ذلك الصين
يعني الحقيقه الصين اثبتت وهي قادره على
ذلك وانا اعتقد انه المعركه استاذي
الحقيقه المعركه
بموضوع التقنيات معركه واسعه جدا وانه من
الممكن ان نصل الى مرحله حتى انه يسمح
للصين باستيراد مثل هذه الرقائق بحيث انه
الصين تضغط بجانب اخر مختلف تماما وموضوع
المغنيتيك وموضوع الذي يسيطر على موضوع
الموتورات الكهربائيه الخاصه بالسيارات
الكهربائيه والصناعات المختلفه تماما لانه
هي تمتلك 90% من الناتج العالمي في في مثل
هذه المساله انا اعتقد انه سوف يصل الى
مرحله كمبرومايز الى مصلحه يعني مرحله
مساومه انا باخذ هذه انت بتاخذ هذه انا
نوصل الى مرحله المقايض والمساومه كما
كانوا في السابق الان يعني انا اعتقد
الصين نعم قادره على ان تجاري العالم كله
وتفاجئ العالم
بموضوع الرقائق وموضوع الاشباء الموصلات
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات من عمان
رائد سمور الخبير وفئه من المعلومات
ومع التطور السريع للذكاء الاصطناعي يرتفع
مستوى توقعات والامال على فوائده
المستقبليه لكن في المقابل يرى فريق من
العلماء ان التفاؤل بشان قدرات الذكاء
الاصطناعي وفوائده في المستقبل القريب
مبالغ فيها
الحل المثالي لجميع مشاكل البشريه العالقه
من الامراض المستعصيه الى ازمه المناخ
هكذا يرى البعض الذكاء الاصطناعي تفاؤل
يتزايد مع كل تطور جديد يشهده عالم الذكاء
الاصطناعي اخره انتشار روبوتات المحادثه
الذكيه على غرار
لكن هناك ما يعارض هذا التفاؤل ويراه
مبالغا فيه خبراء تكنولوجيا يشددون على
اهميه عدم وضع جميع امالنا كبشر على
الذكاء الاصطناعي السبب حسب رايهم انه
عرضه للفشل ويفتقر الى الشفافيه التي
يحتاجها الباحثون لفهم كيفيه توصل
الخوارزميات الى استنتاجاتها بعيدا عن
النقاشات بين متفائل ومتشائم وعلى ارض
الواقع لم يحقق الذكاء الاصطناعي النجاح
المتوقع اقتصاديا على سبيل المثال توقعت
دراسات الاكاديميه عده تحقيق الشركات التي
تتبنى تقنيات الذكاء الصناعي زياده قدرها
ثلاث نقاط مئويه في النمو السنوي
للانتاجيه العماليه
الواقع جاء مغاير كان اداء اسعار اسهم
الشركات المشاركه في الذكاء الاصطناعي
اسوا من المتوسط العالمي لا شك في قدره
الذكاء الاصطناعي تحقيق تطورات مذهله في
مجالات محدده الا انه ينطوي ايضا على
مخاطرها الى خاصه ان الجزء الاكبر منه
يمثل صندوقا اسود مؤخرا حذر يوروبون من
انه قد يستخدم لتنفيذ الجرائم الالكترونيه
ارتفعت اصوات تطالب بتنظيم التقنيه الصين
كانت سباقه في مارس الماضيه اعلنت بكين عن
استراتيجيه الصين الرقميه تتضمن اهدافها
خلق نظام على المستوى القومي لاداره
البيانات والتحكم فيها ومنذ اسبوع استدعى
البيت الابيض رؤساء اكبر شركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لاستكشاف فوائد ومخاطر
التكنولوجيا قبل تحديد كيفيه تنظيمها
مستقبله وطالب البعض
بسيس وكاله دوليه للذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا الاهتمام باحتفالات تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث ما يزال مستمرا وكذلك
المشاركه الخجوله للامير هاري الذي جاء
وحيدا ورحل وحيدا
[موسيقى]
تسببت السيول المتدفقه من الجبال المحيطه
بمدينه تعز في احداث اضرار مديه كبيره في
منازل وممتلكات المواطنين وتعرض المواد
الغذائيه والايوائيه في تلك المنازل للتلف
الى وجهه لا يعرف مستقرها غادر منزله هربا
من مخاطر السيول بمثابه من يقف حائرا على
اطلال الكارثه يبحث عن ملاذ امن انه حال
عشرات الاسر اليمنيه في حي صاله الشرق
بتعز المنكوبين بسيون اجتاحت منازلهم قبل
ايام
داخله والاسره داخل البيت كثيره جدا
وما هي داخل البيت شيوبه وامراض
داخل البيت المنطقه المهدده بالكثير من
الكوارث خاصه وهي تقع في سفح الجبل مباشره
وعلى ممر سيول تاتي من مناطق متعدده
فهي مهدده تماما
بالكارثه
وساحتاج الى عبارات للسيول وتحتاج الى
مصدات لم مواد غذائيه ولا حتى ايوائيه في
المنازل هذه قابله للاستخدام بعد ان تمرت
بالمياه فحتى الابواب هنا اغلقت بالاتربه
التي جرفتها السيول لترسم الى جانب هذه
المشاهد المؤلمه حجم الكارثه على حقيقتها
بالنسبه للساكنين وللبعه ايضا على ارصفه
الشوارع
في الحرازيه للنازحين تضررت عشرات الاسر
وفي منطقه حبيل اوسط بالتحديد في مديريه
صاله عشرات الاسره تضررت وبعض المنازل
تعرضت لانهيارات جزئيه وايضا مناطق في
سائله نفحان ومناطق في بعض مناطق المحوى
في مديريه الصاله اولياء في التحرير من
الاعلى فقط ما يقارب اكثر من 15 بسطه
متضررين ومعدمين يعني
بقيه الشوارع هناك
بساطه تعني بالعشرات خسائر كبيره اذا
تعرضت لها عشره الاسر في المدينه جراء
تدفق السيول الى المنازل لكن خسائر الباعه
على ارصفه الشوارع وصلت الى اكثر من خمسين
الف ريال سعودي بعد ان جربت السيول بضعتهم
كارثه يقول الباعه انها فاقمت معاناتهم مع
دخول البلد في منخفض جوي وتجاهل حكومي
للحد من حجم الكارثه
ال سعيد العربيه تعز
تصريح اليوم مشاهدينا من كاف حول قتل
الروس التي تؤكد صحه قرار بوتين ببدء
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
التصريحوف المتحدث باسم الكراملين ردا على
وعيد مسؤول الاستخبارات في الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بقتل اي روسي في اي مكان حتى
تحرق الرسم شدد ايضا على ان القوات الخاصه
الروسيه ستاخذ هذه التهديدات بعين
الاعتبار وستتخذ التدابير اللازمه من دون
شك
لمن يعشقون تساقط الثلوج ويتمنون القياده
اثناء تساقطها هذا هو المنظر بديع خلاب
لكنه ايضا خطير فكل هذه الكميه ستجعل
سمائك وربما مزاجك بنفس بياضي لون الثلوج
لكنك لم ترى ابعد منها هذا ما اضطر ربما
من وثق هذا الفيديو في استراليا لان يطفئ
محرك سيارته ويترجل
سرعه اليوم من السودان نحن الذين كتب
علينا ان نظل في ترحال يحمل كبيرنا صغيرنا
ونمسك بايادي بعضنا لنتجاوز الدروب
ونجتازها مره الى الشمال ومره اخرى الى
الجنوب نحن الذين اجبرنا على حمل السلاح
وان تكون حياتنا صغيره وبسيطه بسيطه لدرجه
اننا نحملها في حقيبه ون
قضيها
نكتفي بهذا القدر ولكن اخبار الساعه
مستمره وننتقل الى الزميله ميسون مؤيد
مساء الخير يا ميسون مساء الخير الابيض
الحلو شكرا رايه انت الحلوه تفضل نحن
اليوم لدينا الكثير ايضا من الملفات طبعا
الاستعدادات لعيد النصر غدا في روسيا
بالاضافه الى الانتخابات التركيه هو مقتل
المطلوب الاول بتهريب المخدرات في درعا
فضلا عن الكثير من المواضيع وطبعا
التطورات السودانيه ارجو ان تتابعينا
تفضلي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات